now syrians head to the polls today to
vote in presidential elections
only voters in government-held areas of
the war-torn country can cast their
ballot
the opposition claims the poll is a
farce it says president bashar al-assad
who is running for a fourth
seven year term is preordained to win
it is the second presidential election
since the civil war erupted
ten years ago bashar al-assad's face is
all over the syrian capital damascus his
campaign posters dwarf those of the
other two candidates cleared by the
legislature to compete
the final vote tally is expected to show
similar dominance by assad
so why is everyone so sure of an assad
victory to start with
not all syrians can participate only
residents of areas under government
control can vote
in the country that has the largest
number of displaced people in the world
those in rebel-held districts are
ineligible and the autonomous kurdish
regions in the north are not
participating
millions of syrians have fled the
country during its years of civil war
some of those living abroad can vote
like here in lebanon
on the other hand germany has forbidden
the syrian consulate
from registering voters president bashar
al-assad is running against two other
men
abdullah salum abdullah and mahmoud
ahmad
marie who stand very little chance of
winning
they qualified for the vote after an
extremely restrictive process
in parliament all candidates
must have the support of 35 members of
parliament
which is overwhelmingly dominated by
assad's baptist party
candidates must have lived in syria
continuously for 10 years
excluding anyone from the diaspora and
they must be married to a syrian citizen
the united nations has said it is not
involved in the election
and the u.s says without un involvement
it won't recognize the results
syrian media says the regime has invited
observers
but from regime-friendly countries like
russia iran china and venezuela
the last elections were held in 2014 at
the height of the civil war
and saw assad win in a landslide in a
vote that was also widely condemned by
the u.s and the eu
as neither free nor fair
let's get some analysis on this now with
a journalist kristen helbach one of
germany's leading experts
on the middle east and syria kristen
thank you for joining us we saw
there's pretty much no doubt that
syria's president bashar al-assad
will be the winner here he will get
another seven year term in office
is there anything that we should watch
out for that could come as a surprise in
this election
i don't think there's going to be any
surprise president bashar al-assad needs
this election to legitimize his rule
internally and externally because
especially his very strong ally russia
is seeking the rehabilitation of the
assad regime internationally
because syria lies in ruins it needs
money for reconstruction
so what vladimir putin aims at is
reconstruction being paid by the west by
the europeans and the americans so they
want to
put some dynamic into this
rehabilitation of the regime
by claiming this election to be some
kind of democratic by putting two other
candidates there basically
which doesn't make it any more
democratic than it used to be without
candidates
okay but let's talk about that
legitimacy domestically at home
because as you said the country is in
ruins the economy is in free fall
how much support is there for assad
beyond the propaganda that we see
it is very important to understand that
this election is an opportunity for
syrians to prove their loyalty to the
regime
and this is important in a dictatorship
and in a police state
because it gives you security it could
save your life it could save you from
detention
it could bring you some more
humanitarian aid it could bring you a
permission by the secret service that
you need to
maybe get back to your own house so many
syrians use this actually
to say that they are you know on the
side of the president obviously
because they are afraid of being
detained or
being persecuted so this is very
important what we have seen during the
last month is
is a growing discontent and even critics
by
his own supporters by people in the
media journalists judges
lawyers civil servants who have spoken
out especially on social media
on the very bad economic conditions and
the mismanagement of the government
itself
so these people were detained and they
were just released in
just before the elections in this
presidential amnesty
so this is the message to the people
living there look you
don't you are not supposed to criticize
what i'm doing in this country
just go and elect me for now but it's
important to see you know to understand
these pictures when you see all these
people rallying
running for us this is a way to really
save your life or to make
you uh you know to gain a little bit
from this regime and its methods in the
country
and this 10 years after the civil war
erupted in syria
do you think that this election is also
bashar al-assad trying to
take this as a turning point to say the
war has been won
now we look into the future
well he's definitely sending a different
signals
different messages with this first of
all he's saying that he doesn't care
about any un-led process
because there is a constitutional
committee that is supposed to meet in
geneva and that it's supposed to um
create a new constitution first and then
have democratic elections under you and
surveillance bashar assad
delayed the work of this committee for
several months so the last meeting was
in january
and it ended without any result so he's
saying i don't care for you and
processes i'm just going to stay here
he's also saying to russia that he's not
going to go anywhere in a deal you know
that maybe vladimir putin would broker
with the west saying that okay we'll
let bashar assad go and look for
somebody else who could replace him
he's basically saying that he's going to
stay where he is he is dependent
on the people who keep him in power
which is important to understand
it's iran and russia internationally
it's militia leaders
warlords and the business elite
internally all these people want to be
rewarded by assad himself
which makes syria basically a mafia
state because these people are enriching
themselves by bribes by
controlling the black market by
smuggling things by taking humanitarian
aid for their own militia members
so and this is basically what these
regimes supporters are seeing themselves
and what they were criticizing
but bashar al-assad cannot stabilize the
country because he needs these people
who kept him in power until now because
he needs them in the future
to keep him there journalist kristen
helberg thank you very much for that
analysis
my pleasure
you